[Music]
hey guys
before we start this video i just wanted
to mention that only 22 percent of you
are subscribed
so if you enjoy the content please
consider subscribing
to support the channel welcome to
another installment of harry potter
theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing lord voldemort loyal death
eater bellatrix lestrange
and the child conceived by this unlikely
pair i know that emotions run wild when
it comes to the cursed child and that a
lot of you don't consider it canon
but it was written by rowling and she
even went as far as to tweet to her fans
that it should be considered as canon
the issue with this
is that it contradicts the original
storyline in a lot of ways
and in many ways her inconsistencies
have led fans to the point of rejecting
its status as part of harry potter
cannon
whatever your perspective on the matter
this video will be discussing
and including aspects of the cursed
child i myself am impartial as
like i've said jk rowling the original
writer
did say that it's canon which makes it
true but like the rest of you
i'm not totally on board with some of
the decisions that were made
now featured in the cursed child is the
unlikely daughter of bellatrix estranged
and lord voldemort
her name is delfini and she was
conceived sometime in the mid to late
1990s
in secret at the malfoy manor her birth
did actually coincide with the events of
the original books
we just never had any indication of it
delfini who also goes by delphi in the
cursed child
became the only known living heir of
salazar slytherin after voldemort died
in the battle of hogwarts
in 1998. her birth was kept a secret by
her parents
because they feared their infamous
reputations would place her in danger
especially in the event of their deaths
it is unknown what her relationship was
like with her parents or how they felt
about her
as they both died while she was still a
baby but she still went on to inherit
many traits from both of them as she
grew older she became increasingly cruel
sadistic violent ruthless obsessive
manipulative cunning charismatic
intelligent
and the list goes on her calculated
determined
and most of all ruthless nature meant
that she would eventually go on to
murder
craig boca jr an act which swiftly
landed her in azkaban prison
she was fierce tempered and would easily
lose control if things went awry another
trait she inherited from her mother and
father
it's interesting that she would inherit
so many traits from them given
she wasn't raised by either of them i
have often questioned her nature
in an attempt to decipher why it is that
she turned out the way
that she did her mother bellatrix
estranged was one of the most
feared witches in the wizarding world
her fear-inspiring name and bloodthirsty
reputation
were well deserved and she was known to
have murdered and tortured many many
witches and wizards her magical
capabilities were more than impressive
and she was widely considered to be the
one of the most powerful and dangerous
witches of her time
bellatrix lestrange was of course old
voldemort's most loyal follower
and though she served him unquestionably
i do think that she always wanted
more with voldemort she wanted to be his
queen
and to rule over the magical and muggle
worlds alongside him
voldemort on the other hand was not so
keen on a relationship with anyone
this is because he was born with an
incapability of feeling love
voldemort is perhaps the most feared
dark wizard of all time
feared so much that most of the
wizarding world was afraid to even utter
his name
voldemort achieved power that others
could only dream of and he was an
intelligent
cunning and manipulative man that
amassed a legion of followers at the
height of his power
despite appearing to care for his
followers this wasn't the case
as voldemort truly did not care for
anyone he had no understanding of
empathy whatsoever
and simply use those around him to more
quickly achieve his goal of power
if you were to approach voldemort with
your problems he would have no interest
in helping you
with your problems unless he himself was
affected in some way
he was incredibly self-obsessed and was
dead set on becoming immortal and
powerful
so with all of that being said you may
wonder
how on earth he ended up having a child
how could someone who cares for no one
and is seemingly asexual have any
interest in having a child with someone
why would he do it one theory that i had
was that voldemort had a daughter as a
safeguard
he knew that he was the descendant of
his ancestor salazar slytherin
one of the four founders of hogwarts and
one of the most powerful wizards
of all time to voldemort blood status
was important
which is somewhat ironic given that he's
a half-blood nonetheless i can see how
voldemort may have wanted to conceive a
child to carry on the bloodline of his
ancestor salazar slytherin
had he not carried on that bloodline
then it may have put a stop to it
altogether
procreation would have been the only way
to do it and at that point
voldemort would see it as a necessary
thing to do in order to have his legacy
carry on
my other theory is that voldemort never
wanted to have a child
at all but bellatrix who was immensely
deranged and obsessed with voldemort
gave him a love potion you might
remember another time
that the love potion was used i am of
course referring to voldemort's own
parents
voldemort's mother mara p gaunt used a
love potion on his muggle father
and the two went on to conceive a child
because their relationship was
artificial
voldemort was born with an incapability
of feeling love
or emotion which led to his eventual
downfall
was his incapability of feeling love and
it was what set him off on his path of
villainy
from a very young age one of the reasons
that i think that voldemort may have
been under the influence of a love
potion
is the way that delfini turned out from
a very young age
she exhibited traits that very much
resembled her father
she was intelligent calculating
manipulative
and most of all rather devoid of emotion
and empathy
fans have often wondered how someone
like voldemort would have a child
and i think that because of how delphini
turned out the love potion argument
has some merit the only way that delfini
deviated from her father in personality
was that she had a devout obsession with
him for her entire life
she yearned to be with him to have a
father and she was less concerned with
world domination
or conquest bellatrix is just insane
enough to try to use a love potion on
someone like voldemort
and one thing that the films massively
downplayed was how truly and madly
attracted she was to voldemort
jk rowling discussed this in an
interview and bellatrix
was as i think is clear you know i doubt
that people will be particularly shocked
to hear
because i'm sure they've deduced that
bellatrix is madly
romantically in love with voldemort this
is you know
that's the obsession of her life and i
believe that helena bonham carter
had to be asked to turn it down after
sheep the producer called me and said
you know give me some background of
bellatrix so we can tell helena about it
and i said well of course it's a sexual
attraction
she's madly in love with this man and
obsessed by him
apparently they had to ask her to bring
it down because she was being a bit too
sexy
there are also segments from the books
which allude to her obsession with the
dark lord
my lord my lord it was bellatrix's voice
and she spoke as if to a lover there's
also a rather uncomfortable
segment from the order of the phoenix
that a might make you shudder
and be could perhaps allude to the
conception of delfini
maniacal laughter was ringing in his
ears voldemort was happier than he had
been
in a very long time jubilant ecstatic
triumphant a wonderful wonderful thing
had happened
harry could not help feeling that his
first foray into occlumency
had weakened his mind resistance rather
than strengthening it
and he wondered with a feeling of great
trepidation what had happened to make
lord voldemort the happiest he'd been
in 14 years given voldemort incapability
of feeling emotion
i think that a love potion really fits
now the questions are
how long did it last for how strong was
it and was voldemort released from it
before his death
i think voldemort was most likely under
the influence of the potion
from delfini's conception all the way to
his defeat
i say this because if voldemort knew
that bellatrix had given him
anything she surely would have paid for
what she had done
i don't think that voldemort is the type
of man to take things lightly
and i think that he would have killed
bellatrix or worse if he found out
i don't think that he would have been
very understanding but bellatrix who was
madly obsessed with him
was willing to take that risk and being
the powerful witch that she is
likely brewed a potion that was strong
enough to last quite some time
in the case of voldemort's parents
murapi gave riddle the love potion in a
drink
shortly after consuming the beverage he
became immediately infatuated with
merapi
in just a few short months the two were
married and meripe was pregnant
but not long after getting married the
effects of the love potion
faded away this could have happened one
of two ways
number one merope could no longer live a
lie and stopped giving riddle the love
potion
or number two the effects of the love
potion wore off unsuspectingly
and meripe was caught off guard either
way when the effects of the potion were
off
and when tom was no longer bewitched he
was horrified with what had happened
here he was all of a sudden married with
a child to a woman that he had no
attraction towards
dumbledore himself has speculated that
marapi dropped the curse
hoping that tom had genuinely fallen in
love
but in actuality as soon as riddle was
out of the trance
he went back to little angleton fleeing
from therapy
and their son disgusted with what had
happened to him
i think that it's fair to say that
voldemort would be a little more than
just
disgusted and would likely take some
form of action
what do you guys think how was delfini
conceived did bellatrix use a love
potion on voldemort
let us know what you think down in the
comment section down below
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you